Herr bsch freue mich dass das noch mal
geklappt hat was heißt noch mal haben
sie mit der Linkspartei eigentlich noch
eine Weihnachtsfeier in diesem Jahr oder
lässt man sowas ausfallen ich habe eine
Weihnachtsfeier deswegen muss ich auch
hetzen also na klar macht die Linke eine
Weihnachtsfeier aber wir machen das
nicht aber sie ihr Linkspartei machen
Sie noch eine Weihnachtsfeier ja in der
also die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter sind zwar alle gekündigt
aber eine Weihnachtsfeier gibt es trotd
wirklich ja das ist leider so das ist
das Ergebnis also die Entscheidung haben
ja andere getroffen dass die Links
Fraktion in Liquidation geben muss gehen
muss jetzt haben wir den Antrag gestellt
Gruppe zu werden ich glaube auch dass
das sein wird aber im Moment werden
erstmal alle
Mitarbeiter Frau L erklären Sie es uns
einmal kurz als
parlamentskorrespondentin Gruppe ist
nicht sozusagen der Status einer
Fraktion im Parlament ist nicht der
gleiche Status für eine Fraktion hat
weniger Rechte weniger finanzielle
Mittel aber immerhin mehr Rechte und
mehr finanzielle Mittel als z.B jetzt
die Ansammlung von einzelabgeordneten
die sie jetzt leider sind okay und
kürzere Redezeiten auch kürzere
Redezeiten weniger Finanzen in den
Ausschüssen ist man drinne allerdings
darf man auch keinen Ausschuss mehr
leiten aber ich weiß nicht sind sie dann
noch beratende Mitglieder oder sind sie
dann mitstimmende Mitglieder das ist
dann also wir sind dann vollmglieder in
den Ausschüssen und das ist sehr
unterschiedlich in einigen Ausschüssen
ist es so dass es etwas reduziert ist
aber es gibt z.B im Haushaltsausschuss
wenn wir weiter mit zwei Personen drin
sein Finanzausschuss im Auswärtigen
Ausschuss kleine Gruppe hat weniger
Rechte das ist zweifellos so aber ich
ich will nur daran erinnern wir waren
schon Gruppe und wir sind danach wieder
Fraktion geworden und das ist
logischerweise das Ziel geringere Rechte
aber vielleicht eben auch die Chance
dass die lähmende Selbstbeschäftigung
sie haben ja davon ansatzweise
gesprochen dass die zu Ende ist weil das
ist das die entscheidende Frage wissen
Sie wir müssen doch links wirklich was
heißt das in diesem Jahrhundert das ist
die Kernfrage und was machen wir
politisch und angesichts der Politik der
Ampel glaube ich dass das dringend
notwendig ist das sehen wir aktuell
Haushalt und so weiter wie dringend es
notwendig ist nicht Opposition von
W mal gerne das das das formale
sozusagen noch einmal verstehen also
haben sie noch so ein Raum wo sie sich
treffen können dann
haben wir dann natürlich haben wir dann
aber als Gruppe haben wir das dann ja
klar das ist ganz normal es ist faktisch
wie Fraktion nur alles reduziert aber
Kekse Kaffee na die können wir uns
selber leisten das ist ja nicht so dass
Abgeordnete jetzt daen müssen also wir
können uns Kekse und Wasser leisten im
Moment sind wir alle fraktionslos ist
ein Übergangsstadium ich hoffe dass es
möglich schnell zu Ende ist da sitzen
wir da alle als einzelabgeordnete das
ist nicht so schön aber wir haben da
gestern auch spannende Debatten geführt
sowohl zum Haushalt als auch z
Vizepräsidentin aber es ist natürlich da
haben sie schon völlig Recht ist bit
oderade auch für Sie als jemand der nun
so lange jetzt auch in der Politik ist
und und den die Leute ja auch mochten
und mögen ja bitter ist das in jedem
Fall also man muss ja dann fragen warum
ist das so ich habe lange darum gekämpft
dass die Fraktion erhalten bleibt weil
eben genau das das Ergebnis ist und dem
einen oder der anderen wird es auch erst
bewusst werden wenn wir nicht mehr da
sind weil es ist ja nicht das Problem
die Linke ist ja vielleicht ganz
interessant aber gesellschaftspolitisch
haben wir doch eine Situation und die
müssen sich vorstellen die SPD von Olaf
Scholz ist das linkeste was im Bundestag
ist und das ist glaube ich ein Problem
sie mein es jetzt wirklich nur
parteipolitisch ja mein das
parteipolitisch das linkiste habe ich
jetzt gar nicht so gemeint wie sie das
verstanden haben das ist glaube ich ein
Problem und für die Ampel ist es glaube
ich sogar auch ein Problem wenn es nicht
ein stückweit auch politische
Alternativen von links gibt aber
natürlich ein bitterer Tag als der Tag
der Liquidation war der war nur lange
angekündigt wie viele Leute sind da
gekündigt worden ne alle alle über 100
über 100 sind über 100 und dann gibt's
ein kleines liquidatorenteam und wir
werden natürlich versuchen möglichst
wenn wir als Gruppe anerkannt werden und
das werden wir dass wir dann auch
natürlich wieder Leute einstellen und
Politik machen ja und für Sie persönlich
Herr BS sie kennen doch diesen berühmten
Satz von Heide Simonis was wird jetzt
aus mir ja ach wissen Sie ich habe mich
schon im August da waren wir noch
ordentlich Fraktion habe ich was aus mir
wird klar gesagt ich habe jetzt gesagt
ich übernehme die Verantwortung und
werde diesen Prozess dass wir Gruppe
werden nicht nur begleiten sondern auch
verantworten das ist auch allgemein
anerkannt in meiner nie so viel
Anerkenntnis gehabt wie jetzt jetzt
mögen sie plözlich alle ziemlich vi das
deute darauf hin dass man mittle mit
ihnen hat das natürlich nicht gut nein
sind quasi der Insolvenzverwalter nein
das bin ich ja nicht das waren sie ja
schon mal ne weder noch sie wissen ja wo
die SD Milliarden sind da haben wir be
schon länger drüber unterten hab uns
schon länger drüber unterhalten damals
schon gesagt und kann ich ihn gerne auch
noch mal darlegen weil das haben andere
bei der Suche über gerne gerne gerne wo
fahren Sie hin ich komme mit und dann
können wir graben die letzte F nach Wien
Ernst nach Wien ernsthaft wiederum
natürlich ist das jetzt mehr als ein
Einschnitt und ob wir wiederkommen das
wird ja nur daran entschieden ob wir bei
der nächsten Bundestagswahl im Parlament
sind als Fraktion oder nicht das die
zentrale Frage und ich habe wie gesagt
die Bereitschaft erklärt jetzt genau
diesen Prozess dass wir Gruppe werden
nicht nur zu begleiten sondern wir sind
wir ja noch nicht wir sind ja alle im
Moment fraktionslos ich glaube aber dass
das sein wird und dass wir uns dann so
konstituieren mit natürlich Reduktion
inhaltlicher Themen aber ganz klar als
die soziale Opposition als
Friedenspartei das ist uns und dann nach
der nächsten Bundestagswahl sind sie
noch dabei oder nicht aber die Frage im
Moment will ich erstmal Gruppe werden
also das ist wenn ich das hab sie ihre
Lebensplanung meine Lebensplanung ich
mach mirim ein bisschen Sorgen um sie
wissen Sie ich muss sorgen
okay geh ach mir geht's eigentlich sehr
gut das ist eten Z Bundestag das habe
ich wirklich diese Frage entscheide ich
nicht jetzt und die entscheiden dann
andere die sie denken doch darüber nach
ich kann da viel drüber nachdenken die
entscheiden andere nämlich diejenigen
die dann die Verantwortung haben in
Partei und in Gruppe die sollen das dann
auch entscheiden und wenn gewünscht
bin fit und
ich vermute wissen Sie wissen Sie ich
bin ja Abgeordneter aus Meklenburg
Vorpommern und in meinem Bundesland
regieren wir schön in einer rotroten
Koalition ich habe auch die
koalitionsverhandlung mitgeführt das ist
sehr erfolgreich in meinem Wahlkreis in
Rostock größte Stadt mcklenburg vorpom
stellen wir die oberburgermeisterin also
die Linke ist ja da und die Linke kann
wiederk überall ja nicht überall nee in
manchen Gegenden weiter südlich ist es
etwas dünner aber insgesamt müssen wir
wieder dahin zurück wo wir herkommen
nämlich dass wir in besonderer Weise die
Interessen der ostdeutschen wahrnehmen
da sitzt jemand der über sie sagt Frau
Lehmann dim bsch ging es um vieles im
Laufe seines langen politischen Lebens
aber vor allen Dingen immer um ihn
selbst ich um seine Macht ist das jetzt
zu böse formuliert nein ich möchte mals
Recht geben in dem Sinne dass es
tragisch ist dass die Linke aus dem
Bundestag verschwunden ist erstmal
weil das ist nicht gut für die
Demokratie weil die Opposition die wir
jetzt haben im Bundestag die kommt von
rechts und von ganz rechts und das hat
man jetzt aktuell auch diese Woche schon
gesehen als es um das sogenannte
rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz ging da
waren als Sachverständige natürlich die
eingeladen die alle Fraktionen im
Bundestag einladen aber keine einzige
flüchtlingsorganisation und da fehlt
eben die Linke auch als linkes Korrektiv
also insofern schlecht für die
Demokratie aber natürlich Herr bsch das
muss ich so sagen haben Sie auch einen
gewissen Anteil dass es dazu gekommen
ist denn die Leute die jetzt aus der
linken ausgetreten sind und die sich als
von der Fraktion dann auch abgespalten
haben das waren ja auch Leute mit denen
sie jahrelang Bündnisse geschmiedet
haben die sie gefördert haben oder in
einflussreiche Positionen boxiert haben
z.B Amira Mohammed Ali die jetzt den
Verein von Sarah Wagenknecht aufbaut das
ist die Fraktionsvorsitzende deren Wahl
sie unterstützt haben oder Klaus Ernst
ist weg da haben sie gesagt der soll den
ausschl Ausschuss für Klima und
energieleiten ähm ein ja ein wichtiger
und der einzige Ausschussvorsitz den die
Linke hatte und der ausgerechnet von
einem Mann angeführt wurde der in der
Fraktion gegen den Aktionsplan
Klimagerechtigkeit den sie mitgetragen
haben gestimmt hat also alles sachlich
nicht motivierte Entscheidung die allein
machttaktisch äh zu deuten sind so sehe
ich das und in insofern ist es schlecht
dass es jetzt so ist aber sie haben
einen gewissen Anteil daran und das muss
man so leider sagen wenn ich dann eine
Bemerkung zu also das mit dem Anteil
stimmt das wäre ja irgendwie kurios wenn
ich sagen würde ich habe damit nichts zu
tun aber ich will nur darauf verweisen
sowohl was Klaus Ernst betrifft als auch
meine ehemalige mitvorsitzende das waren
demokratische Entscheidungen ich meine
ich habe da auch eine Stimme ich will
aber vor allen Dingen darauf verweisen
wir waren ja viele Jahre sehr wohl auf
der Erfolgsspur und ich war im übrigen
die einzige Bekannte aus der Abspaltung
Sarah warnknecht mit der war ich ja
Spitzenkandidat und wir haben über 9%
erzielt Fraktionsvorsitzende wir waren
auf einem erfolgreichen Weg ich finde
dass es viele Verantwortliche gibt für
die jetzige Situation ich ziehl
zweifellos dazu das sage ich deutlich
und selbstkritisch das ist so ich habe
lange versucht die Fraktion
zusammenzuhalten und habe das auch immer
bis jetzt finde ich das richtig diesen
Versuch unternommen zu haben aber
letztlich gab es
viele viele Gründe dafür aber die Wahl
von Klaus ernt na ja das das ist so ein
Punkt da könnte man jetzt eine ganze
Sendung
fen machen wir mal zu zweiten
Sondersendung mit Frau Lehmann aber das
interessiert die Leute vielleicht nicht
so richtig ist was sie sagen es ist im
Moment eine Tragik dass es so ist und
wir müssen schauen ob wir diesen Platz
wieder ausfüllen können das ist die
entscheidende Frage um die es geht und
das ist natürlich auch eine inhaltliche
Frage ist ganz klarau die die wir
sollten finde ich einen Punkt machen an
der Stelle weil es so viele aktuelle
Dinge zu besprechen gibt also Haus halt
ist so ein Stichwort Frau Lehmann Herr
bsch hat geschrieben die Ampel einigt
sich da jetzt ne ging um die Frage die
Jagd nach den verschwundenen 17
Milliarden waren es ja die wir jetzt
erstmal brauchen auf dem Rücken von
Beschäftigten Familien und Rentnern hat
er da recht
ja da hat er der also da hat er einen
Punkt denn es ist ja so es wird jetzt
quer über die gesamten knhaushalt
geguckt wo kann gespart werden und die
Kernbotschaften die ulaf Scholz und die
die Trias also Scholz Linden hab gestern
gesetzt haben wir machen weiter also wir
machen weiter beim Klimaschutz wir
unterstützen die Ukraine weiter wir
machen weiter beim Umbau der Wirtschaft
aber liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger ihr
müsst euren Beitrag dazu leisten der CO2
Preis steigt um 10 € pro Tonne äh die äh
der der der Strompreis sinkt nicht
sondern im Gegenteil wird wahrscheinlich
auch noch steigen wir noch ein böses
Erwachen geben bei dem Thema und genau
und die Leute werden das merken die
werden das merken beim Heizen die werden
das merken beim Tanken die werden es
merken wenn sie irgendwie ein Gerät
anschalten insofern finde ich das auch
problematisch weil bei den Leuten kommt
ja jetzt nicht an wir haben jetzt nicht
am Sozialstaat gespart bei den Leuten
kommt an wir machen Klimaschutz und wir
unterstützen die Ukraine und wir sollen
es bezahlen und das ist verheerend das
ist verherend weil das wird populistisch
mit Sicherheit ausgeschlachtet werden m
wie schaut da der Ökonom drauf Rüdiger
Bachmann der zwar in Amerika lehrt der
aber deutsche Politik sehr gut kennt wie
ich weiß meine wenn man sich das mal so
klar macht was da jetzt gerade passiert
ähm Heizöl beispielsweise wird ungefähr
um ja fast 5 Cent glaube ich pro Liter
teurer werden
Benzin Diesel knapp 4 € 4 Cent um es mal
ganz Kop zu sagen und wenn wir über
Strom sprechen da fällt ja sozusagen der
Zuschuss für die Netzentgelte plötzlich
weg das heißt da werden wir darüber
reden dass es einen Anstieg auf
6,43 Cent pro Kilowattstunde gibt das
heißt das das ist richtig drastisch was
da passiert werden Leute merken das
stimmt auf der anderen Seite würde ich
sagen die Politik macht sich hier auch
ein bisschen ein Stück weit ehrlich im
Sinne von wir haben diese meakrisen
diese polykrisen in der Ukraine und
die Klimakrise ist sowieso eineer der
megakrisen unseres Jahrhunderts und am
Ende wird es jand bezahlen müssen äh die
Frage ist sozusagen wie die
verteilungspolitische Wirkung ist und
ähm insofern finde ich den einen Teil
schon richtig dass man Dinge äh das ist
auch immer wieder ein pldoier von
Ökonomen gewesen dass man Dinge die
Umwelt schädlich sind verteuert da dazu
gehört der CO2 Preis das ist im Prinzip
richtig allerdings äh führt eben die hö
höheren Einnahmen jetzt des CO2 Preises
eher zur
haushaltsstopfung dafür dass habbeck
weiterhin bestimmte Projekte
Lieblingsprojekte finanzieren kann
nämlich das gebäudeenergiegesetz die
Subventionen die da gezahlt werden zum
Teil auch Intel möglicherweise und äh
und eben kein klimabonus kein klimageld
ausgezahlt wird diesem Topf wie
versprochen wurde und das ist glaube ich
diese Kombination aus diesen beiden
Dingen das ist glaube ich äh
verteiligungspolitisch durchaus nicht
unproblematisch sagen wir mal und kann
natürlich dann politisch in den nächsten
in den anstehenden Landtagswahlen ein
Problem werden und dann gibt's ja auch
noch so andere offene Dinge bei dieser
ganzen bei dieser ganzen Sache wie
ziehen wir jetzt noch mal
äh die notfallklausel oder nicht ja also
da wird jetzt gesagt da hat man sich
jetzt auf so eine Sprachregelung
geeinigt das ist sehr interessant was da
für den fürs Atal machen wir das noch
mal aber im Grundgesetz gibt's das nicht
im Grundgesetz kann man nicht eine
spezielle Notlage ziehen man kann nur
die Notlage erklären oder eben nicht man
kann nicht eine spezielle Notlage fürs
ahal erziehen erklären für mich das hört
sich so ein bisschen nach man wünscht
sich hier sozusagen unbefleckte Ausnahme
Erklärung für die Schuldenbremse die es
aber gar nicht gibt ja und das weiß ich
nicht ob das erstens nicht auch
politisch ein Problem werden könnte wenn
bestimmte Oppositionsparteien oder auch
Zeitung dahinter kommen dass das eben
sozusagen ein komisches labeling ist es
könnte aber auch verfassungsrechtliche
Risiken nach wie vor bedeuten also heute
haben verfassungsrechter oder gestern
schon haben durchaus namenrechte verfass
namenhafte verfassungsrechter ich bin
keiner ich nehme das nur zur Kenntnis
gesagt dass das möglicherweise Problem
sein könnte die Frage ist ob die
Opposition dagegen klagen wird wegen
diese 2,7 Milliarden das ist offen aber
wenn es dazu kommt kann es
interessant ist nur ganz kurz die
Einschätzung noch mal der
parlamentskorrespondentin und Elm möchte
glaube ich auch
Olaf Scholz hat ja ist es ein Trick ein
rhetorischer Trick den er da bemüht wenn
er sagt sollte sich die Situation durch
den Krieg in der Ukraine verschärfen
dann werden wir darauf reagieren müssen
das heißt März hat es direkt so gedeutet
wir werden uns das gleich mal anhören
nach dem Motto wenn dann leider sehr
viel mehr Geld für die Ukraine plötzlich
notwendig ist dann werden wir natürlich
die Notlage erklären m nee das ist kein
Trick ich glaube das ist der Versuch
abzusichern dass die Unterstützung für
die Ukraine so weitergehen kann wie sie
wie sie weitergeht er hat ja auch darauf
hingwiesen dass man das in dem Falle
macht wenn die Lage an der Front sich
verschlechtert oder wenn andere
ausfallen und damit ist er zum
Europäischen Rat gereist also andere
ausfallen das ist natürlich kann
natürlich einerseits die EU sein also
Orban blockiert und das kann natürlich
andererseits aber auch die USA sein und
darauf bereitet man sich eben jetzt vor
und wie bereitet man sich darauf vor
eigentlich müsste man sagen man müsste
man müsste es eigentlich finanzieren aus
dem laufenden Haushalt aber man hat ja
noch so viele Investitionen die man
hochtätigen muss und die werden durch
die Schuldenbremse nicht zugelassen also
die Schuldenbremse verunmöglicht
eigentlich dass man alles zugleich
machen
kann bei der Ukraine ist es ja okay aber
der Trick ist ja beim Atal zu sagen wir
wir machen über wir ziehen die
Ausnahmeklausel fürs Atal ohne dass wir
die Schuldenbremse im ausnahmemodus
fahren also sie wollen Ihren cake ihren
Kuchen haben und
Essen das ist ja der wi aber liebe Herr
bmann das ist doch aber sehr
übersichtlich warum das Atal genommen
wird niemand von der Union wird sagen
wir helfen den Leuten nicht das ist do
der Punkt und bei der Ukraine ist das eh
nicht klar sie haben aber davor den Kern
ja gesagt wir haben jetzt schon die
höchsten Energiepreise in Deutschland
die Haushalte das ist doch der also ich
habe ja überhaupt nichts dagegen Dinge
zu verteuern aber Auer außer
Lichtenstein und Belgien bezahlen nur
die Haushalte in Deutschland so viel das
ist die Wahrheit und da können wir
andere Dinge nehmen und es gibt
Steuererhöhung das ist ja die Wahrheit
und wenn man in dieser Situation
ernsthaft sagt was wir nicht machen ist
bei den Superreichen ranzugehen ist
Milliardäre das ist alles uns alles egal
da machen wir gar nichts da gibt's keine
Steuererhöhung aber für die Leute gibt's
Steuererhöhung die Mehrwertsteuer wird
angehoben auch in Gaststätten betrieben
was ein wahnsinniger Punkt ist der CO2
Preis ja das sind alles dingeung
zurückgenommen alles hat hat der
Bachmann Punkt ne es wird eine Senkung
zurückgenommen was die Gastronomie
angeht
ich ge ih aber recht ich gebe ihn aber
recht her weil ich glaube die Leute sind
zu einer Menge bereit auch zu
Klimaschutz und auch zu Unterstützung
der Ukraine aber Sie müssen das Gefühl
haben es geht gerecht dabei zu und wenn
Sie das Gefühl haben das bezahlt vor
allen Dingen die Mittelschicht aber
vermögende sind dabei total nur wegen
Symbols das ist das symbolis schon
wichtig wir wir fassen wir finden uns
damit ab dass in der größten Krise die
wir hatten die Zahl der Milliardäre
steigt und ich sag noch mal Milliardär
also wirklich das wird man nicht durch
eigene händearbeit das ist einfach wahr
und die Multimillionäre werden mehr da
muss man wenigstens symbolisch sagen wir
wir wir reden darüber und nicht das
kommt nicht in die
Tüte dann ist das ist wirklich Christian
Lindner der Interessenvertreter des
Geldadels und das darf nicht sein da ist
er wieder der alte
Klassenkämpfer gar nicht jetzt Alter
rassistisch gemeint gut sonder nur
politisch ich glaube zwei Dinge dazu das
eine ist dass das Verfassung richt jetzt
tatsächlich gezwungen hat ehrlich zu
werden aber es ist nicht erkenntlich
dass sie es wirklich werden wollen weil
sie selber haben alle in der Regierung
ja den Anschein erweckt in den letzten 2
D Jahren als könnte man diese
sonderanstrengungen alle so nebenher
machen ohne die Bevölkerung ernsthaft zu
belasten ich nehme mal das Beispiel
Ukraine zu glauben dass die Verteidigung
der Freiheit im Grunde genommen zu
machen ist ohne dass man selber
Nachteile hat jetzt recht sich dass man
nach dem ersten ich sag mal Mitleid mit
der Ukraine
kein narrativ geschaffen ist hat warum
es wichtig ist die Freiheit zu
verteidigen in Europa
m das Flüssiggas das uns über den
letzten Winter geholfen hat kam aus
anderen Ländern die es nötiger gehabt
hätten da sind Tanker umgeleitet worden
die eigentlich nach Asien unterwegs
waren und wir haben hier im grundeommen
den Vorteil davon gehabt das heißt es
muss eigentlich auch das mal beendet
sein immer den Anschein zu erwecken es
geht zu Nulltarif und das zwei
was bei mir im Kopf rumspukt ist das was
wir drüben wirtschaftlich erleben in den
USA in den USA wo die Schuldenbremse ja
ganz klar nicht gibt sondern Schulden
gemacht werden ohne Ende aber es gibt
sie in amerik gib gibt eine andere Form
die aber eigentlich noch absurde ist
weil die Amerikaner versuchen sozusagen
Arithmetik einem Gesetz Vorbehalt zu
unterwerfen als die Amerikaner Stimmen
zunächst mal über haushaltsgesetze ab
der wird abgestimmt steuern und Ausgaben
und und da der normale Mensch würde dann
sagen die Schulden sind eigentlich die
Restgröße die aufgenommen werden muss um
die Ausgaben zu finanzieren aber die
Amerikaner dürfen dann noch mal oder
müssen dann noch mal abstimmen das heißt
man erlaubt dem amerikanischen Kongress
quasi über Mathematik abzustimmen was
natürlich noch viel absurder ist als das
was wir in der Verfassung das ist für
mich der entscheidende Punkt es wird
seit dre Jahren eine Wirtschaftspolitik
in den USA gemacht die darauf setzt eben
zu stimulieren in einem Ausmaß was ganz
offenbar erfolgreich ist so dass es in
Australien und auch von der Opposition
in Großbritannien als Modell der Zukunft
gesehen wird während man hier in
Deutschland auf die Schuldenbremse pocht
obwohl die diversen Krisen erfordern
dieses ein Stück weit aufzuweichen und
zu lösen
also gibt es tatsächlich eine
Möglichkeit mit diesen massiven Ausgaben
genau wirtschaftlich besser
voranzukommen als mit einer
Schuldenbremse und einer
Austeritätspolitik also interessant ist
ja FRN eigentlich muss man doch sagen
dieses dieses ganz entscheidende Thema
die Frage woher kommt das Geld in dieser
Ampel ist ja im Grunde von Anfang an
sozusagen auf diesen beiden ja wie soll
man sagen Lebenslügen aufgebaut also
Robert habbeck sagt wir wir machen
Klimapolitik und zwar sehr sehr massiv
mit Geld das wir nicht haben und
Christian Lindner sagt aber wir halten
Schuldenbremse dabei das das läuft alles
und alle wissen das ist quasi so eine
Art ja trixerei SAS esken hatich hier kN
genannt oder was auch immer es ist auf
jeden Fall nicht ehrlich und was es ja
auch ist es ist Ausdruck eines sozusagen
Robin alexander hat das neulich so
beschrieben sagt der eigentlich ist es
Ausdruck sozusagen eines politischen
Kompromisses der nötig gewesen wäre
Lindner und auch habten beide
aufeinander zugehen müssen den hat man
aber nicht gefunden man hat sich nicht
ehrlich gemacht und deswegen sind wir
jetzt in der Situation in der wir sind
und jemand wie friedriich MZ vielleicht
können wir uns das kurz vorher angucken
der der der riecht das der beschreibt
auch sozusag sagen was da kommen wird
und es ist sehr interessant ob diese
Prophezeiung die er jetzt getätigt hat
ob die möglicherweise Wirklichkeit wird
wir schauen mal rein und der Trick ist
doch durchschaubar sie geben jetzt das
Geld aus dass sie im Klima und
transformationsfond haben sie geben das
Geld aus was sie für die gesamten
Transferleistungen in den Arbeitsmarkt
aufwenden wollen und dann werden Sie uns
zur Mitte des Jahres sagen tja das ist
nun alles unvorhergesehen gewesen was da
in der Ukraine auf uns zukommt und jetzt
müssen wir noch einmal die
Haushaltsbeschlüsse überprüfen Herr
Bundeskanzler das Grundgesetz sieht eine
unvorhergesehene Notlage vor für die
Überschreitung der Kreditgrenzen der
Schuldenbremse sie wissen dass sie das
nicht einhalten können was sie heute
morgen hier gesagt haben es ist eine
vorhersehbare Notlage die sie spätestens
zur Mitte des Jahres erklären werden
müssen und dann wollen sie uns in Spruch
nehmen noch einmal für die
Überschreitung der verschuldunggrenze
des Grundgesetzes diesen Trick lassen
wir Ihnen nicht
durchgehen re das Problem ist dass er
dass er Recht hat ja das Problem ist
dass er Recht hat ner weil z.B nehmen
wir das Bürgergeld das sind luftbuchung
vorgenommen worden alle die Formulierung
das Problem ist dass er Recht
hat ich verstehe Thema wo
sindekommen zustimmen muss bei dieser
Frage dass hier unehrlich agiert wird
und das ist es so das ist einfach so die
haben zusammengesessen haben sich eine
Kommunikation überlegt hatten
Überschriften die stimmten das ist ja in
Ordnung dass man das sagt wir wollen
weiterhin die Ukraine unterstützen wir
wollen weiterhin die Transformation der
Wirtschaft vorantreiben aber das wird
letztlich nicht untersetzt und das ist
das Problem dieser Koalition dass sie
sich völlig richtig nicht ehrlich machen
in dieser Situation ist die
Schuldenbremse eine zukunftsbremse nicht
nur die USA man kann auch in andere
Länder schauen jetzt muss man
investieren das ist also liegt so auf
der Hand und wenn man dann sagt wir
müssen das in dem Rahmen ma machen dann
muss man mal schauen wo man dann real
kürzen kann das ist ja schon noch
interessant wo gekürzt wird und wo nicht
ich finde das hoch problemematisch und
deswegen deswegen hat Friedrich Merz
leider recht es ist so dass mit dieser
Politik es sein kann dass zur
Jahresmitte wir in einer Situation sind
weil die haushaltsrealisierung eine
andere sein wird dass wir dann in einer
Situation sind dass die Schuldenbremse
doch noch mal gilt wie jetzt das ist ja
genaau und Kuriosum wir haben im
Dezember im Dezember morgen werden wir
beschließen dass äh der Haushalt für
dieses Jahr angepasst wird und wenn es
dann nur das Verfassungsgerichtsurteil
wäre wä es ja okay stimmt ja aber gar
nicht es ist viel mehr was aufgenommen
wird das ist die Wahrheit heißt heißt ja
das heißt dass ich die Regierung jetzt
am Freitag ganz leise ehrlich macht für
dieses Jahr wo alles vorbei ist und für
nächstes Jahr versuchen Sie ähnliches zu
machen deswegen hat er an welcher Stelle
an welcher
Stelle wen man sagt wir wir finanzieren
you never alone wir zahlen das alles na
ja das ist das ist ein Punkt da müssen
müssen man jetzt in die Details gehen
was sie alles dort entschieden haben
aber ich habe ja das Beispiel Bürgergeld
genannt da wird eben gesagt also es wird
weniger in Anspruch genommen werden wir
geben weniger aus aber warum welchen
Grund gibt's dafür da gibt es keinen und
so ist bei vielen anderen Dingen auch
dann wird gesagt wir werden den Klima
und transformationsfond auffüllen mit
anderen Dingen und deswegen kann Robert
habbeck seine Wünsche erfüllen wir
werden selbstverständlich Intel und
Dresden das werden wir alles machen mit
der Förderung ich bin sehr gespannt die
Haushalter werden das irgendwie
zusammenschrauben aber am Ende kommt
genau das was mer sagt raus und das ist
ein Problem ich habe wirklich null
Sympathie dass die Union hier als großer
Sieger hervor schon vielleicht wäre das
eine Option für Sie mus man muss
vielleicht Z Ehrenrettung der Ampel mal
sagen dass sie diese sie man nennt es
sie nennt trixerei oder wie auch immer
oder Herr März nenn so dass sie das
nicht angefangen haben es gab ja auch
schon zu Zeiten Angela Merkel zahlreiche
sondertöpfe ich glaube 15 war es sie
allein zu merkelzeiten eingerichtet Word
schon in den 50er Jahren
ne schon sehr lange das Problem ist
diese Schuldenbremse die ist ja nicht
vom Himmel gefallen oder Gott gegeben
die wurde dort reingeschrieben und zwar
von einer großen Koalition von Union und
SPD und da hat man Unterstützung also
man ich kann noch mal will noch mal
sagen wer das mit unterstützt hat und
das war auch die FDP und die Grünen im
deutschen bundesag Bundesrat Bundesrat
haben die Grünen Landesregierung alle
die Link war dagegen das kann man auch
so sagen insofern ach ja
dastim und und insofern dort hat man
diese völlig aberwitzige Grenze von
0,35% Verschuldung vom biip
reingeschrieben das auch eine völlig
willkürliche Zahl wo gesagt wurde
eigentlich Ergebnis eines politischen
Deals und was von Menschen dort
reingeschrieben wurde kann von Menschen
auch wieder rückgängig gemacht wordden
herrz hat ja auch das Problem dass er
sagt wir werden das auf keinen Fall
zulassen aber seine eigenen
Ministerpräsidenten mittlerweile sagen
wir müssen da vielleicht irgendeine
Lösung finden und das genau ist das
Problem weil se eigenen
Ministerpräsidenten zum Teil ja auf
ähnliche Art und Weise und und noch mal
und noch mal und noch mal zum zum zum
Schluss also wenn man sich mal also die
Deutschen sind ja mehrheitlich für diese
Schuldenbremse weil sie sagen ja es ist
richtig aber privat und als Unternehmen
macht das natürlich niemand dass er sagt
wenn ich mir eine Wohnung oder ein Haus
kaufe oder irgendwas teures anschaffe
oder eine neue Maschine dann spare ich
so lange bis ich es bis ich es auslegen
kann sondern natürlich wird jeder ein
Kredit aufnehmen und sagen ich schaffe
das jetzt an das rechnet sich in der
Zukunft und genau das darf der Staat
zurzeit nicht